seven Italian doctors are facing trial
after refusing to perform an abortion on
a woman who later died the woman in
question was reportedly five months
pregnant with twins when she suffered
complications she fell seriously ill and
according to her family the doctors told
her that the twins would not survive but
refused to perform an abortion on moral
grounds later the woman miscarried and
died of septic shock her parents blame
the hospital for her death but the
doctors refute the claim the doctor told
me look there is no hope for the babies
but even though Valentina is in pain we
can't intervene as we can still hear
their heartbeats with the right
antibiotics and removing the source of
infection Valentina
would be alive there was no
conscientious objection on behalf of the
doctor that intervened in this case
because there was no voluntary
termination of the pregnancy but the
miscarriage was forced by the grave
circumstances I rule out that a doctor
could have told the family what they say
he told them abortions have been legal
in Italy since 1978 but the law gives
doctors the right to refuse on moral
grounds unless the mother's life is in
danger
according to reports the number of
doctors in Italy refusing to perform
abortions has risen by 10 percent in 12
years many women travel to other regions
for the procedure some resort to illegal
abortions we got opposing reactions to
this particular case Valentina me Lutz
Oh Valentina Nelson would still be alive
if she had been given an abortion the
Catholic Church in your life is alive
and even babies who are going to die two
hours after birth should be born anyway
the story is not an isolated incident
it's a countrywide problem in Italy and
quiet often sick women are transferred
from charge hospitals to regular
hospitals when they are refused
treatment when the doctors in church
hospitals diagnose a birth defect some
of them ask your mother what is the name
of the baby that is there in your uterus
they try to convince her not to
terminate the pregnancy even if they
know the baby will be born only to die
just because they believe it should be
so these babies died and the mothers can
now be protected by an abortion I know
it's hard as many of those women want
but I'm convinced that they have the
right to be informed beforehand about
the risks and that it must be a woman's
considered choice if she wants to take
the risk
I'm pretty much against abortion morally
speaking not only because I'm a Catholic
he could become a city because I think
there are so many way to prevent
pregnancies now even in 78 when the
Italian law was issued on the birthday
that I think really abortion is a crime
and the law basically is full of
imperfections is not complete law is not
clear lot in a doctor I still live in
certain cases so I think the law should
be changed
I think abortion should be allowed only
one would know and we make sure that the
fetus is carrying a major major disease
mental disease or physical disease and
song
you